g/km workers from the unites Union have
protested outside Parliament and lobbied
MPs to stop a hostile takeover of the
footsie 100 engineering joined by
Melrose the seven point four billion
pound bid is opposed by GKN but the
union wants business secretary Greg
Clark to use his powers to block it in
the public interest workers fear Melrose
would break up GKN which is involved in
key defense contracts like the f-35 and
typhoon fighters and we've jobs overseas
one of those braving the cold of
Westminster was Unite's assistant
general secretary for aerospace Steve
Turner and he joins me now Steve good to
see new roads have been great managers
of business why are you so upset about
this takeover well we wouldn't accept
the premise of the statement the male
voice a group manages a business I mean
males have no experience of managing a
company the size of GKN is the third
largest manufacturer in the UK of course
and five times larger than anything
Melrose has ever had any engagement with
previously but we wouldn't be here if
GKN had been better run over the years
well Jake owns nine trouble deacons a
good stable business in core sectors of
the economy by here in the UK and indeed
across Europe and in the u.s. mail why
was his turnaround business a short term
business we classified them as an asset
stripper they take over businesses
normally by indebting them and they're
proposing to put 1.4 billion pounds
worth of debt on the balance sheet of GK
and in order to pay shareholders a
one-off dividend that's not good for GK
and it's not good for UK plc your
business well except the GK and of
course as part of their defense strategy
are going to sell off the powder
metallurgy business which is one of the
more exciting parts of what they do well
we're in discussions with GK in at least
we can discuss with GK in the future
proposals for their business there's no
doubt that GK will need to change into
the future and we're part of that
process of change Melrose however on the
other hand have refused to even sit down
and discuss their business plan for for
GK and post any takeover Melrose is a
three to five year turnaround business
GKN is in the business of 10 15 20 year
R&D programs with some of the largest
manufacturing companies across the globe
including major defense contractors of
course I mean one of the things that
they are going to do GK and assuming
they survive this is break themselves
into the
they currently have a big engineering
aerospace engineering on a big
automotive hiring I mean does that worry
that they're gonna break themselves up
anyway it seems well we're talking to
decaying about that and we'll deal with
that after we've dealt with the male
wives beard our priority right now is to
get the government actually the
Secretary of State for BAE's great Clark
to intervene the government have the
ability to be able to do this in the
national interest we regard this as
hugely significant for our interest on
national security grounds there isn't a
major defense product that GK and has
not got his fingers in it's a Tier one
major supplier invest huge amounts of
money with the state actually not just
the British state but other European and
the US government's as well in defense
procurement if you take that supply
chain out of the equation this is a
hugely vulnerable business but if you
look on the mo d-zone websites GK or not
aren't even there us one of the top 15
suppliers well because they're not a
prime they're not a prime manufacturer
they supply into a supply chain and it's
the synergies in the supply chain that
are crucially important what Melrose
will do of course is for short-term
profit because that's what Melrose are
they're all about shareholder value then
all about job security or communities or
skills or futures sovereign capability
in the areas of Defence or anywhere else
for that matter they're into short term
shareholder value but in three to five
years turning around selling it on so
this business will be broken up and sold
to the Chinese the Russians are very
often our opponents of course not just
in a business sense sometimes in a
defense sense as well and it's that
insecurity will to destabilize this bid
I believe isn't your problem though that
I mean the government wasn't prepared to
intervene to stop arm holdings which is
a much bigger company chip designer
wasn't prepared to stop that being sold
to the Japanese what hope realistically
have you got a preventing g/km from
being sold but that was a mistake
government should have intervened the
government proposes at least industrial
strategy for the UK UK plc well this
drives the coach and horses for any
industrial strategy hopes that the
government may have and therefore on
those grounds alone the government
should if it could intervene and should
do what it can but there are specific
grounds on national security defense
matters that do enable the secretary of
state Greg Clark to intervene so we call
on him to do exactly that
and to stop the bid weigh its tracks
where is now all right Steve Turner from
the unite unit it's very good to see you
are the first person we've been able to
get on camera to talk about this
takeover bid so she can't yeah well GK
and a Melrose you know where we are we'd
love to see you as well